yo what up this is belly make sure you
check out my interview
on the bootleg cav podcast let's go
all right yo it's the bullet cap show
man we got a special guest in here my
brother
belly yes sir welcome sir i had to pull
up man
of course man um i've been extremely
privileged to actually
listen to your new album that i don't
know when it's coming out
i don't know when it's coming up but but
you got you've got you got a few records
out from the album
um you just dropped the money back yo
project or song uh rather and video
right videos out yep
um but this album is um
it's got some uh i don't want to give
away too many of your secrets but it is
uh
man i mean you've had in my opinion like
projects that i consider personal
classics like for me
um but this project feels like uh
some of these names you got on the same
songs have never been on songs together
and they're like the biggest of the big
like this album feels like
i know it's not your debut album i know
it's not in any means your date
but it feels like like a like your
biggest moment is like still
still to come like yeah absolutely man
and
i feel like the more the more i created
with this album like the further along i
got into the album i was like
all right there's some there's something
happening here you know i mean like just
the
songs we were able to create together
and stuff um
it was just like a different experience
even creating it was different this time
i really took my time you know normally
i'm just like
you know i want to just get it it's been
a few years man
because immigrant came out in 2018 2018
yep and that was your last project
yeah that was the last one that's insane
yeah what made you um take so much time
off
i'm gonna say off but take so much time
to work on a body of work i guess
honestly it wasn't all working on this
project
first was working on me yeah i was gonna
say well i wanted to get into that
because i know you went through some
depression and [ __ ] the last few years
and yeah it was like it was
it was like deeper than that you know i
mean like you know
they put titles on on things we go
through you know what i mean but
um yeah i was i was just i was just in a
position where i had been in the game
for so long
i had kind of experienced you know the
ups and the downs of the game and that
you know i mean everything
was to kind of you know feel and
i don't know man it just got to a point
where i was like it's all i've ever done
like i got i want to i want to just sit
down and just see what
what my what you know what my brain
comes up with you know
and really it was it was like an
investment in myself because i didn't
really work or at least like um
you know work in a way like where like
money was coming in all the time like it
was right i had to like
block that uh you know that financial
[ __ ]
uh yeah because you you you you're
always motivated by
the bag as an art you know what i mean
it's like yo when you have so much money
coming in
and that and you kind of have that
mental expectation in your head like
i'm sure that's hard a hard thing to
turn off yeah but
it was like it was at a point where it
was like cool i could
i could die right now with however much
money in the bank
and then you have your residual money
coming in anyway from publishing and
music and all that but yeah but i mean
you know when when you when
when you sit down like like the career
that i
was blessed enough to build right it
sustained
a lifestyle that i was blessed enough to
live and then when you
cut that you really realize how
crazy uh you know
spending habits just just just just the
way i was living was just crazy you know
i mean so
it was it was a good time for me to just
sit down and just like reassess
everything
and uh and like really see i was like
you know how they say like
let you know let the bird go and if it
comes back dmx said that and that's all
i remember dmx said that if you love
something let it go yeah that's
facts that's really facts because like i
was like yo you know what
if this is this is really for me the way
i know it's for me deep down the side
but
that don't matter right now like if it's
really for me then
something will draw me back to this and
and i'm gonna come back and i'm gonna
feel
better about it than the first time i
ever did it you know i mean so
as far as music music yeah yeah so so
that's that's how music started to feel
like like you started to feel like work
before the break before the hiatus you
know
yeah i have a job absolutely and it
wasn't like
i was you know being told like do this
to do right it was just going in the
studio was just like
all right like you know like what now
you know what i mean
and you know it just it just it was it
was the best thing i think the smartest
thing i ever did in my life was to just
sit down for a second and just
take a breath and just you know figure
things out what was that motivation
initially
where you you came to a point where you
were like i gotta do this like i gotta
it was it was it were you just
overwhelmed like was there a breaking
point where you were like
if i keep going down this path i might
go crazy or something what was it
i think i was just like so focused on
all the negative things that were going
on in my life you know what i mean
and it was a lot of things it was things
on the family level
right things on uh you know obviously
financial levels and
all everything you know there's a lot of
things going on with my career
everything um so i think i think like
when i initially when i wanted to step
back and and
you know really take the break it wasn't
like a decision i made it was
i just can't go there right now you know
what i mean
they're like oh there's this this thing
going on or this event or this session
or whatever i just
can't i can't go there right now i can't
like
i wouldn't even i would be doing you a
disservice if i showed up
in this state like i'm not i'm no good
to nobody right now i just need to go
somewhere and just figure my life out
you know i mean so
that's what i did it wasn't like a
specific moment it was just like me just
just being so repelled by the other [ __ ]
that i just wanted to get away from it
you know
and what what um because i remember i
tapped back in with you i think late
last year or something with talk and you
were like yo man
you know i've went through a real bout
of like being down you know what i mean
and
what exactly like was the breaking
through point for you where you were
motivated again to make incredible music
because
your album is incredible thank you man
thank you um
i'm blessed i'm blessed to be around
some geniuses
and some people that do what they do at
the highest level you know what i mean
and i think
uh just getting to watch abel first hand
you know the weekend first
of course music and uh just crazy run he
was on i mean still i mean just that
album i feel like it's just
i've never seen an album with more legs
like yeah man
but he's going to tour for that album
next year and it came out 20 nights each
like it's crazy
and honestly the album deserves it
because it's like those are the things
that inspire me when i watch someone put
together a masterpiece like that and i
got
front row you know seats to the show
like
that's that's inspiring those were some
of the moments that made me be like yo
yeah you know what i do i do love this
there's something about this that i
that like you know it's something that's
different than anything else on the
planet
nothing else can make me feel like this
so
those those are the moments that started
to kind of swing me back you know i mean
yeah i mean creatively like i feel like
you're kind of uh
when i meet other belly fans it's like
we're like we're like uh
it's almost like an exclusive sneaker
club or something you know what i'm
saying like
like like if you know you know type [ __ ]
like oh you [ __ ] with belly oh [ __ ]
like yeah you know what i mean i love
that though i love that
i love that man yeah because i i still
feel somehow you're still
you still don't get get your flowers as
far as just
your talent in the in your catalog and
you know when we talk about
the best rappers and obviously you
haven't you know you've taken taken a
few years off but just in general i feel
like your name is
should be in more of those conversations
it's cool i think it will be
you know i think it will be like
i get to feed my family with this man i
get to support my life i get to do
whatever i basically want to do doing
something i love every day
you know i mean by the way congrats i
know you and your girl uh
just took a big step yeah yeah you told
me about it uh like like last month or
something
right yeah absolutely man you had to go
to uh new york to like meet her family
yeah yeah when i met the family amazing
people man it was like
you know it just showed me you know like
when you look at somebody's family and
and they're that good you're like okay i
know exactly where you came from
and if i remember correctly you were
saying your your girl's catholic or her
family's catholic
and you're obviously from a muslim
background right so
when you went out there you tell me the
story about uh you you
gifted her parents something you had to
go get a statue somewhere
yeah i mean it wasn't i didn't have to
it was but no but but but you got
you you know you went out there to make
an impression obviously yeah as we all
have
universities yeah yeah i think um
yeah man i went out there and honestly i
was i was nervous because
in other times and other points in my
life when this situation would arise
like with you know previous
relationships
or whatever man i would i would show up
to the house and
they would man they would go in you know
i mean like they would
i would be in an interrogation room
basically right
you know and and so i think this time i
was like mad nervous you know i wanted
to make sure i did everything right
and uh you know i went bought the gift
obviously i bought some wine and i went
to the crib and
mind you i don't i don't really get
nervous over a lot you know what i mean
like it really takes a lot to get me
nervous i was damn near shaking you know
but from the first moment man like the
door open
you know her pops was just like open
arms invited me in it was it was for me
it was a new experience i've never i've
never
had that happen yeah yeah you know so it
was just really dope to have um
to have like that type of like welcoming
response and
just really really good people man are
you uh
is this because obviously you know being
belly being somebody who's uh your
your raps are extremely uh descriptive
when it comes to women and [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
is uh is it how hard is it for you to
like like
make a conscious decision to be like you
know what i found the one like is it was
that
because i think we've all been in
situations where
we are we think we're in love but i
think a lot of it is lust
right but to really find that one person
you know i just got married a couple of
years ago it's like
it just feels different man like and
like you could
again you have a that's the best thing
in the world though yeah it's really the
best thing like
you know um like from
for me i think when i when i found that
i wasn't looking for it that was the
best that's the best part about it best
part about it is like
i don't think she was neither you know i
mean it was just
it just happened and i think that's like
i know it sounds cliche and all the guys
some real [ __ ]
but that's really me and my wife like i
didn't i was no
i got out of a real shitty man uh not
marriage of a relationship with my son's
mom it was terrible and
i was like all right finally i'm free
i'ma just
get a crap is it good yo yo yo yo yo
all right um but i was like ready to
just
take down i was ready to catch some
bodies in these streets
and then i'm her and i connected and i
was like damn
look at this i was not expecting this
[ __ ]
that's really how i'd be man and like
i'm i'm
i'm over all that other [ __ ] like i said
like the the light the like the life
quote-unquote yeah like i think you know
we've lived that [ __ ] man that should
turn me off so much that i
walked away from the game like that's
like that whole [ __ ] i think comes with
so much baggage and like of course
evil [ __ ] around it like i just it was a
good thing for me to leave all of it
and then on top of that just having
somebody like dina in my life like
she was it was like an important moment
for me to meet her
um go into my next like where you were
in life like she kind of
yeah i feel poor man like she really
even when i was down on my
you know at my worst like she nurtured
me back leveled you up man got you back
yeah
and you know it's a blessing bro like i
that to me is one of the best things if
not the best thing that ever happened to
me is
you know locking down with one person
and having one person that i know got my
back and i got hers
that's amazing bro um why is the album
called see you next wednesday
man so i man i go down rabbit holes with
[ __ ] you know what i mean so i
with movies and all that of course john
landis
you know he directed like thriller a
bunch of hit movies in the
early 90s and uh he would always sneak
that
into his movies see you next wednesday
it'll be like a billboard
or like a thriller when michael jackson
gets up to walk out of the theater
you hear the voice whisper see you next
wednesday in the background
that was like his easter egg and a lot
of his movies right
um so i thought that was cool just just
like that
yeah i was just like oh that's dope as
hell like i'll just you know i want to
pay homage to john landis you know what
i mean
and um i dug deeper obviously the rabbit
hole
you know i mean you'd be high as [ __ ]
just trying to find out more right
and finally i got to the to the
to the gist of the whole thing is that
was the first script that he wrote
and it never got made right
and in the in that position that i was
in in that moment it was it was crazy
because when i read that i was like
okay now i know why this is like kind of
calling my name
you know what i mean because the way the
dots connected it it just felt like the
same thing i was going through it's like
i'm making some [ __ ] right now
i don't even know if this is going to
see the light of day i don't know if i'm
going to come back to let it see the
light of day
you know what i mean so when you were
working on this project you were just
working on it for you
you weren't working on it like to to
turn it into your label or to like yo
this is a hit
or you know now you were just working
yeah yeah it was honestly for me it was
like
getting in there and and and testing and
challenging myself
to be like okay which we did yesterday
sucked you know like i had to like
really just give myself
talks because you know like i said it
was like relearning all of this [ __ ] you
know you walk away from it for so long
it was always my outlet like my way to
like say things and all that you know so
it was really hard uh to not have that
anymore
to be going through [ __ ] that i want to
talk about and i want to be able to put
in songs but
it's just the way my brain is taking it
it's not letting me
you know what i mean it's not letting me
put nothing on paper i can't
think of nothing witty to say around
these things or nothing poetic to say
around these things it was just too
black and white in my head for me you
know what i mean so
i think it was like a challenge to
myself to get in there every day and be
like
oh [ __ ] that like i'm alright i gotta
break this wall and like
do what i do you know just you know it's
really what i do best you know so
day by day i really just had to just
build myself back up
and you know god bless the album ended
up being what it was but really if it
didn't go there
and i wasn't as proud as i am of this
project and that really would have been
my see you next wednesday john landa
style
yeah i think you and i might have even
had like uh i think we each when i said
that was my favorite song you're like
that's crazy because that was my
favorite so i'm trying to remember what
the name of it was
i don't want to give away it wasn't any
it wasn't a record with a big feature
though
might have been something to do with the
devil or demons or something was is
there a record like
i'm trying to think there was some pride
some man
the album is crazy but i feel like on
this project you definitely touch on
a lot of personal [ __ ] that um
you've you've always kind of grazed over
a lot of your personal life like [ __ ]
with your pops stuff like that like
i feel like on this project like you
really dive into some some issues that
you you know you've gone through and
[ __ ] like
um talk about just your journey with
with with drugs and [ __ ] because that's
something that you've always been very
upfront about
yeah um whether it's get like
being super loaded on [ __ ] getting clean
you know et cetera like
where how are you doing now you know
when it comes to obviously
we're not talking about weed and [ __ ]
you know i mean when it comes to the
other [ __ ] yeah yeah i know exactly
yeah yeah um i quit like
quote-unquote hard drugs right right
right i quit a couple years ago
um hard liquor too i don't drink hard
liquor no more
so you don't you when you say hard
liquor so you're not drinking tequila
you're just
not just just wine wine maybe like maybe
sake
sometimes i mean stuff like that but uh
it's just like weed wine and
psychedelics for me
you were talking uh me and you had a
dope conversation about psychedelics uh
but right before you came on you said
you were
thinking about writing a book or you're
gonna write a psychedelic inspired book
right
absolutely yeah what's it you you what's
it gonna be called
how psychedelic saved my life tell me
how they saved your life man
well i think again the rabbit hole yes i
started reading a lot of a lot of
literature
about um just dosing what different
doses could do for you
and it just all depends on the effect
that you want
you know what i mean so um i started
micro dosing
in the middle of wow [ __ ] that was going
on of course of course
i started micro dosing i'm not gonna say
like
oh it was like this magical [ __ ] just
wake up and everything is
you know chipper right right it was like
slowly over time like i started to gain
a little more clarity
and uh you know it just it just kind of
helped me find
not even like a happiness but it just
helped me find like like the
like the beauty and a lot of [ __ ] you
know i mean like i'd go outside and be
like damn that's a that's a [ __ ]
beautiful flower you know
right i would have never stopped before
you know so i just i don't know it just
and i was micro dosing so it wasn't like
making me like hallucinations
or nothing yeah it was just like um
kind of just uplifting my days you know
when it was going on
and i think um you know from there
that was like lsd micro dosing in water
and then do shroom tea most of the time
yes i've never done the shroom tea so
how much will you put in the tea
like because it depends really like
depending on what kind of day you're
trying to have yeah like i like a light
vibe like i might put
a half a quarter okay to the whole pot
which is like you know six probably six
tea bags
right and um
that right there like if you want to get
[ __ ] up you still can if you drink all
of it more than a few glasses
you know what i'm saying like you'll
definitely get [ __ ] up but
i just sip it slow i'll be in the studio
working creating [ __ ] not super slow and
it's just
it's like a it's like a different type
of vibe man it's just it's like
like it helps my brain in different
types of ways so when you say
psychedelics will save your life
do you would you say because i for
people who don't know i think a lot of
people don't understand like
the therapeutic benefits of
of shrooms and even mdma you know what
i'm saying in certain instances but
but is that would you consider like your
experience with psychedelics to be
therapeutic
absolutely it didn't used to be right it
used to be more probably recreational
right
it used to be yeah it was it was
recreational and it's like i was sitting
in between
where like the the positive effects
would be
you know there's like the hero dose
which is
all all i mean yeah it's gonna make you
discover yourself and then there's the
micro dose which is
you know for your mental health right
you know just just
like again yeah if you micro dose you
can have a productive day you go to work
you can you know do all that should have
a more productive day
yes that's i think that's why people do
it yeah so you haven't done the hero
does yet
because i remember we talked and you
were saying that you you want to do it
but
but you're not ready yet yeah i just got
to get out
you know i'm still like coming out the
dark space i want to be fully out before
because that's something that's
something that's like
serious well you know that's that's man
it's
for me look shrooms never really sat
well with me
uh when i was younger like when we were
taking shrooms recreationally like
i i used to bat trip like all the time
wow i mean like
and i don't want to say like bad trip is
so you know overused but
right right i mean just like you know
that uncomfortable
kind of dark feeling yeah it turned into
a [ __ ]
burton movie you know for sure like
that's that's how
a lot of my trips started to feel like
you know so
i think shrooms my love for shrooms came
back when i started micro dosing shrooms
and making tea and stuff like that
because i was like
okay this is the dose that my body
appreciates right this is what my this
is exactly what i like you know what i
mean
and it has has been like i said man's
been therapeutic life changing since
then
have you dabbled in uh in dmt yet
no it's very uh crack headish
i mean you literally smoke it out of a
crack pipe so just be
if you ever decide to do that i'm i'm
i'm definitely not um
you're gonna disappoint anything out of
a crack you're gonna disappear for 15
minutes
just you're gone yeah i've heard i mean
a lot of my friends have done it you
know
and and stuff like that but that [ __ ]
and then the other [ __ ] is the ayahuasca
which is like a tea but that you you got
to do with a shaman
go to costa rica you know i mean you can
do it in orange county you know what i
mean
yeah send me the address i'm gonna go
yeah nah nah that's that's told me i
think i think
like uh money man just tweeted this the
other day he was like we're not doing
uh pills no more only shrooms he was
like the first
rapper in that kind of space that i saw
kind of say that you know what i mean
cause i'm like yo a lot of these kids
are so [ __ ]
you know perked out fentanyl and all
this [ __ ] and it's like man i think i
think shrooms has
got to be the next wave bro that [ __ ] is
all them pills and all them opioids and
all that [ __ ] is so
garbage man yeah so garbage this is
dangerous
i feel like you're gambling with your
life every time you do it because you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're getting
it's it's like it's a sad thing to see
bro for real because
you know you're only you're only here
one time
it just takes one bad pill yes take you
off the map
you're only here once man what was the
worst experience you had with drugs man
where maybe like you were like damn like
that this [ __ ] really
i gotta reconsider what the [ __ ] i got
going on over here
um i had a bad situation happen to me
a couple times but the one that always
comes to mind is
i was in new york you know i was like
uh going through a breakup at the time
you know [ __ ] was just just felt you
know for me
a lot of times when i get in them dark
spaces i just feel like the world is all
against me everybody's against me
everything else
you know what i mean yeah so i just sat
in my hotel room
i answered the phone and i just got high
bro
like whatever i could get my hands on i
was just like just trying to escape
whatever my reality was at that time
then i woke up
uh on a bathroom floor yeah
wow and like oh all right here was
bruised i guess i have fallen fell on
your face probably yeah i mean
[ __ ] and that was like that was like the
awakening for me
that's the beginning of the end i didn't
i didn't quit there
i didn't because i was you know still
messed up you know what i mean but yeah
man so it's also a lot if you're on that
[ __ ] regularly
people don't understand how hard it is
you just like to quit cold turkey off
some of that [ __ ] is not
healthy yeah to be honest you know
but i'm glad man i grew a lot i think um
i'm the type person i got to experience
things i gotta like
you could tell me a thousand times what
something might do
the stove is hot the stove is hot yeah
you gonna fight you gotta break yeah
all right cool yeah you're right you
know like that's how i am so
you know it was a blessing in disguise
it really showed me everything that i
never want to be um
that's some real [ __ ] i think i think
too like like you said like we we
i mean especially you and i probably
similar in age we kind of came up in a
different era of
socially when it came to some of those
drugs and
i think it became so like it's so
accepted to
get into certain drugs that if it was
the 90s people would like clown you for
and like you said like you know you you
go through
a situation like that it really makes
you look at yourself and be like
damn i i if if i was looking at me from
another person's body
look at this [ __ ] guy like that's
really what it is and honestly that's
see i approach life like outwardly like
that because
you know people be like oh yo don't you
know don't don't get around this person
or
this this guy's a bat and i'm like yo
you could learn what not to be from
somebody
and it could be equally as important as
learning what to be from somebody else
you know what i mean
and i had to learn what i didn't want to
[ __ ] be you know that was
that was that moment and looking and
being like yo the same
i don't like this for myself you know um
i want to shout out to the homies the la
leakers because i feel like you've uh
you just did three for three on the
freestyles
that first one uh was so crazy i i felt
because that first one happened after
the flex one that i thought
was that that was after the flex one
right yeah what flex did is top
freestyle and you put you in there was
the [ __ ] weirdest [ __ ] ever but
anyway
i digress um but yo you you came that
that
that first leakers freestyle was so
crazy because
um i know hove was a fan of it
and there were so many like i feel like
that kind of woke a lot of people up
as far as like you know who the [ __ ] is
this guy belly who do obviously people
didn't know who you are already but like
how important
was that first freestyle to like just
everything for you you know what i mean
because i feel like it really kind of
puts you in a whole another
space yeah i agree and that really had
more of an effect in some of my you know
biggest songs or like singles
right that were out so
i go back i probably listen to that i
think twice a month man i'm forced to
listen to it i still get tagged and not
freestyle
every day you know hero villain it's all
perspective that's bad
you know false elections yeah but yeah
it
did a lot for me man it really changed
my life and
i think the the dopest part about it for
me
was what it did just amongst my peers
you know mm-hmm
because a lot of a lot of you know uh
colleagues or people in the game that i
know or work with or just
vibe with whatever you know we know of
each other's talents you know what i'm
saying but
i don't think uh a lot of even like my
own friends or peers
knew you had it like that knew i was
gonna go in there and do that you know
so i think
you know it just it just uh like gave me
like this new found kind of like
uh perspective or gave other people like
a new friend
right people who weren't already tapped
in yeah for sure so
i think that was like the dopest part
yeah was that um
because that freestyle came out in was
it 2018
i think it was 2018 was it was it
earlier was it 2017. it was earlier than
that was maybe 2017 then 2017 probably
because after that you did mumble rap i
feel like and mumble rap was like i
think a project that
no doesn't get talked about enough
because it was just bars
i mean it was like you know it was
it was something i had to do man at that
point and i think at that point not a
lot of people were putting out projects
like that like i feel like now
especially because of what you know
griselda did and
you know came back and literally just
put they stomped the [ __ ] game out
with this [ __ ] yeah i mean so i feel
like now everybody's
really inclined to want to you know put
out rap music and
come back to the bars and you know yeah
i think what happened to
because i think you know grizzle has
been active around that time they were
active you know i just think that um
i think that what was dope about the
pandemic um and obviously
zelda was on fire before the pandemic uh
but i think it just kind of made people
listen to music differently
because they weren't standing on couches
anymore they had to listen in their car
or at home or in their headphones
so i think if you like look at the best
rap album category from the grammys last
year it was like
that's a lot of it's a lot of just bars
in this [ __ ]
so i think you know guys like freddie
gibbs and royce the five nine
and all these guys who've been putting
in work i just think it was like
last year was such a good year for real
i'm not talking about
them like now now we know freddie and of
course of course no no
no we know they're gonna put out some
rap [ __ ] i'm talking about people that
we wouldn't expect to put out rap [ __ ]
right now right right
being like yo you know like like [ __ ] i
could rap you know what i'm saying
trying to and trying to do something
that maybe three or four years ago they
would
have tried you know what i'm saying no
that's for sure nothing i think like
that shift is is kind of like
evident now no i think so too and i
think it's been it's
it it's great for me as a fan because i
listen to like money back yo's album and
i'll be like yo
there's some [ __ ] on here that i
wouldn't have heard you know
and i love yo's album like but there's
some [ __ ] on there and i'm like this is
some ill like just hip hop [ __ ] like
yeah man money bag yo one of them guys
bro talented
very talented guy [ __ ] talented um
as a hip-hop head yourself who are you
like obviously you got benny uh
on on the project i mean you got some
other legends on the album
um but who are you a fan of right they
say we got knives
oh i don't know listen i don't want to
be good okay so you got nods on the
outside yeah so we got nines
boozy the weekend uh no nothing we can't
say that
oh okay so bleep that
uh the weekend now i'll let you tell
everyone who you're comfortable with the
telling who's on the album because i
don't
yeah yeah yeah so we got the weekend in
nas it's a joint called die for it okay
so yeah so they're on the same song
together
all right cool we can talk this song's
[ __ ] crazy thank you it's [ __ ]
great
and we shot the video i'll show you the
video uh
we're talking like yo this [ __ ] gotta be
like victory type video like oh man
yeah i think uh you know it's an
incredible visual bro like it's it's
just
it really looks like a movie obviously
benny
yeah yeah michelle uh money bag yo um
yeah money bag yo um
man i got able again on another joint
yes but you know that'll come out he's
got a total of
three no the third one is just he's just
doing better no but he's on there though
but he's just doing the background focus
because i remember when i heard it
you're like yo that's him doing
background vocals i'm like bro you gotta
you gotta run your arm three times
technically that's pretty crazy yeah man
it's is super dope
what was it like um like
wrapping up on a song with nas because
that is scary yeah that's got to be
scary right
you know like obviously it's a [ __ ]
one of the biggest honors of my life
of course [ __ ] you know what i mean it's
somebody that i've learned from and
respected and looked up to
you know half my life so
but it's scary man it's like
i hope knives don't wash me on this [ __ ]
you know i mean that's that's really how
i felt
and um my verse was there it was already
done
by the time i sent it you know so you're
you had to
send your verse in like because some
people will you know they might get the
nos verse back and they might revisit
their verse
that's that's that's against the rules
man okay yeah so that's the unwritten
rules but some people do that
shout out to you remember ll did that on
the 4321 jordan that's how the whole
cannabis [ __ ] happened
i didn't even know that yeah but nah so
so when you got nazi's verse back were
you like
i held my own i mean man i'm
i'm just i'm just glad he did what he
did on it man he killed that [ __ ] and i
think
for me it's all i think it's gonna cut
through no matter what because it's like
a personal verse you know what i mean
it's like some real i talk about some
real things
and i think that's always gonna cut
through you know i mean people are
always gonna feel that type of thing so
first time the weekend and novice have
done a record together yeah
yeah amazing what is um
abel's influence on the album like how
how cause i i know you guys are very
close obviously
he's on the project a lot but as far as
just like like
when he hears like does he give you
notes does he give you his thoughts you
know what i'm saying
hell yeah hell yeah bro he's he's super
involved man like i can't say enough
about that dude bro
like with everything um that he's done
as an artist bro like what he's done as
a person and just for like the people
around him and
you know just the just the blessings
that he's that he's been able to bestow
on
different people and just the world in
general and just help
and all that like it's to me it far
exceeds
even what he's done musically which is
top tier no he seems to be like
just from like an outside perspective
obviously i'm cool with you and manny
and sal and those guys but like
he seems to be like probably like one of
the exceptions when we think of just
like
people who made it that big that are
just like
loyal as [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
and he just
he's just himself 24 hours a day like
you're not going to knock him off his
axis like he's himself
he's always going to be that no matter
what that's why
you know he doesn't get weird he'll
never be like that boogie type of heart
ever yeah you'll see him at like like
you'll see him at random [ __ ] you'll be
like oh
oh that the weekend's just right there
he's for the people man yeah i mean
trust me
yeah no it's crazy um you have some
writing credits like
obviously with i want to say someone
just told me that they looked at the
writing credits on blinding lights and
you have do you have credits on that
record
yeah i do um you know like with that
stuff
i'm sure you've heard me say this before
too you know like
i i never like to go into the
songwriting stuff or like what i you
know
what what people see credits on right
because like that can mean a bunch of
different things by the way yeah and
like and not only that it's like
um especially with somebody like you
know the weekend or like
a lot of the people i work with which is
the type of artist i love to work with
are people that
create their own world they create these
songs and then
you know abel's pen is crazy ridiculous
like the guy could write his ass off you
know i mean so
um for me it's just like it's kind
of like a blessing to me to be like yo
[ __ ] you want to
you know you want the fact you
contributed like yeah like
like i'm i'm exactly i'm i feel just
blessed that uh
that you know different artists feel
like a compliment to something they
already got
you know i mean yeah because i feel like
you know for me to
you know give give a record or whatever
you know it could be a demo you could
get a demo
and might like it and you might record
it and i've had songs you know
go like that but like the artist that i
really love to work with it's like i'm
i'm really coming in
collaborative effort and and it's like
it's something that's already there you
know what i mean it's it's like
something that the artist has had such a
great vision for already
you know like i said like those are the
type of people that i like to work with
no that wreck is crazy because that
record is like obviously one of the
biggest songs of the last
25 years but it's also a record that was
so brave cause
it just felt like the 80s it felt like
it felt like something like we jumped in
a time machine and it was like
it's like such a nostalgic record but
it's also like a current pop hit
like oh yeah like it and then the whole
album had that heartbeat
for sure yeah when you heard when like
like when you first heard that record
like
prior to whatever you contributed like
like did you feel like oh [ __ ]
this is cause this is legit i mean i
think it might be the biggest song of
the last five years at least i mean i
i know it just lived in the top ten on
billboard
i'm just i'm just proud that we win as a
family bro that's that's really
that's really the best part of all of
this you know in the super bowl man
that's what i'm saying like the fact
that i could look around
and you know see guys that i've known
for at least a decade
all around me and everybody's successful
at what they do
everybody's happy that's that's the
greatest feeling in the world that's
like you know what i mean
other than individual wins of course
which of course like you know you got to
feel good about but
regardless man just being able to look
around at the fam and see everybody in a
good position bro that's
that's the dream yeah man um
what is this something i wanted to talk
to you about
that has obviously had escalated since i
saw you last i saw you about a month and
a half ago
um you know i know you're very
passionate about what's going on with
your people overseas
um in palestine and um i've tried to do
my best to
educate myself on a very complicated
situation um
but i think that you know me and you had
kind of spoke about
like um how it's like it could be i'm
sure it could be frustrating because
it's like
i feel like there's only so much you
could say before people try to like
label you some [ __ ] that you're not like
you could be very um
critical of government of countries
right you know without
being somebody who's criticizing a whole
people
absolutely um i would never in my life
criticize the whole people i'm just not
i'm a human hey interrupting the
interview
to tell you about our good friends at
odd socks now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
ooh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have
underwear that's right you can get your
odd socks underwear
the boxer briefs are the best underwear
that you could ever fit on your ass
trust me when i tell you
these are chucky draws what you know
about top ramen underwear all right
go to oddssocksofficial.com use the
keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20 off of of your order
underwear masks slippers socks
whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kevin checkout save 20
all right back after the intermission we
had mic issues but we're here
well no i mean obviously man i was
bringing up you know what's going on in
palestine
in gaza um it's a
a complicated situation but it's also
really like on a human level
aspect it doesn't seem very complicated
yeah i don't i don't think it's it's
very complicated
um you know
for palestinians it's been a struggle
for a long time
and um it's like this this like cycle
keeps repeating
over and over you know i mean it's like
it's hard to see
real change happen when people
aren't being told you know the whole
story about what's really happening over
there
you know what i mean and again you know
like i really feel like
uh it comes down to it comes down to
people having to hold their governments
accountable
and that's i think that's the only way
we could change
you know the the status quo the way they
even perceive us and look at us and
stuff like that is like
you know it's dehumanizing end of the
day
it's like you know palestinian people
some of the most resilient people in the
world of course gone through
some of the worst atrocities and
all anyone's asking for that anyone
that's speaking out all anyone's asking
for is
some compassion some compassion some
human rights
and you know not not to see the
situation through biased eyes to
actually just look
and do the proper research and then you
can come up with your own answer
you know yeah i mean from what i've
gathered is like
obviously what transpired during ramadan
um how the like you know i i spoke to uh
my friend adam rice who's jewish and his
his parents go to israel every single
year
and he was like we're wrong in this
thing man like what did like
like why would you do that to those
people
during their holiest time and expect
like
things like you know what i mean like
like nobody like would ever think to do
that and expect anything good to happen
of it you know what i mean
and even peter rosenberg who you know
again is obviously a jewish man you know
what i mean me and peter talked about it
pretty extensively and that's my god and
he married kind of mirrored the same
thoughts you know and i think
it kind of comes down to like you said
holding your government accountable
in the same way that if donald trump's a
piece of [ __ ] and
somebody from [ __ ] europe is like
man donald trump's a piece of [ __ ] that
doesn't mean
the americans are pieces of [ __ ] it
means that yo you know and i've heard
that the guy who
and again i'm not like the craziest like
as far as like who's
like being educated on the ins and outs
of the government in israel but i've
heard
from people who i trust that like yo
essentially the guy who's
running [ __ ] in israel is like their
version of trump like hardcore right
wing like
crazy like crazy neocon
type ass [ __ ] so yeah it's just
rough man because like you'll see some
of these images of these people and it's
like dude like
this i mean his his own government is
holding him accountable and
he just got ousted from his position a
few days ago see i didn't know that yeah
you know he's on corruption charges
being accused of bribery you know it's
all kind of this is
not a it's not a a
favorable human you know what i'm saying
so
it's easy to see how somebody like that
could really
you know put poison the well yeah and i
think too what people have to understand
too and this i've always said this about
america like just in general
like yo like if you're
what do you expect to happen if you're
like imagine if you're a kid
in gaza right and somebody bombed the
building you live in and let's say you
lost your mom
like what do you expect that kid to grow
up feeling about
you know what i'm saying it's almost
like it's a cycle that'll never end
until it ends
yeah i mean
you know to me i i feel like it's just
gonna have to come down to people
just just looking at it as a human issue
yeah politics on the side
you know there's there's civilians kids
dying
you know and the thing the thing about
the whole
you know we're we're going to hunt a
specific
militia or whatever right and it's like
i'm all for it you you want to go uh
find some some criminals or whatever the
case is and not in that
particular situation i'm talking just in
general vaguely yeah
you know but um
you you shouldn't be killing civilians
to go get to the people
that you're mad at for killing civilians
like it doesn't make any sense there's
got to be a better way
to approach all of this which is also
what happened with the united states
like obama
and the drones and i mean this [ __ ] has
like happened so much where it's like yo
at what point in time
is getting the bad guy worth killing a
bunch of innocent kids
you know what i mean like this is crazy
because again it's like who suffers bro
yeah and then and then and then it's
almost like the psycho gets hit
on repeat because imagine all i can only
imagine if i grew up somewhere and
someone
some my my parents or my sister died or
my best friend died like how i would
feel about
whoever the [ __ ] did that for the rest
of my life and it's like it's just never
i
you know it's just it's almost like the
gang [ __ ] you know what i mean like we
always talk i talk to the homies who are
you know gang bangers out here and and
like i'll be like yo like what is the
like how's the violence he's like how
are you going to tell somebody to not
turn up on that crew when they
they they took their brother their
cousin well you know what i mean it's
it's like
what like you said it's got to be a
human rights thing man and i think
unfortunately i wish like our government
would have stepped in and done more but
like you said earlier it's like that
politics [ __ ] comes into play yeah
again once you throw all that politic
[ __ ] you know out the window
and that's why i wish we had bernie man
and you just stop and you and you have
some emphasis you [ __ ] with bernie
right
yeah yeah yeah i thought i think
bernie's like the illest [ __ ]
like
he should have been our president bro oh
yeah bernie's great man he's jewish
right like and he don't give a [ __ ] like
he's like yo it's about human rights
yeah this but this thing ain't about is
the thing is it's not about
being jewish right no but you know what
you're right and we know that and we can
have that conversation but
the internet and twitter and it's like
you're either there or you're here no
there's no in the middle bro i got
people from all walks of life so do i
jewish muslim
christian catholic buddhist whatever you
want to name
atheist whatever you want to name 100
that
i consider some people i consider family
friends
colleagues co-workers whatever
um that to me never means nothing bro
it'll never stop my love for you it'll
never stop my support for you it'll
never stop
nothing everybody just has a stop
and look at it from a human
issue take the tribal the tribal [ __ ]
away take the take all the political
people government take all the all the
bias
all the things you want to feel take
those away and just be like yo let's
just look at what's going on here
you know what i mean no matter where you
are and what country you're from if you
love your country you're gonna hold
your government accountable until
they're doing the right thing talk about
so you for people you know you you've
been an independent artist for a very
long time before you were [ __ ] with
xo
you've uh you were you know i remember
seeing your name
for a long time i remember i think you
had a record with the game
and you've been doing your thing for a
minute
um obviously coming into the xo4 i
didn't have a record with the game was
it snoop uh
two records it was snoop it wasn't the
game it was snoop yeah me and game never
worked together no it was snoop
yeah okay yeah it was snoop i was i was
either snoop in the game i was gonna say
snoop at first
um but uh
you come out with exo you have a smash
record like
might not with with with the weekend
having a record like that
is it like a gift and a curse i mean
obviously it's a gift more than anything
but like
that's such a big song like it's
it's i mean did you find yourself ever
chasing that record
like at any point in time no way
no that happens sometimes when you come
because honestly for me and my
my background of what i come from right
like like i i
let songs go all the time you know so i
have no
personal attachment to records and what
that did for me like the mentality that
it built inside of me
was i could do this again like
i don't i'm not going to be married to
this song if if this person as a vessel
could push this song further than i can
then who the [ __ ] am i to stand in my
own way you know what i mean where that
came from guess what
i wake up tomorrow and i'll make another
one it doesn't have to be that
right something that dope you know what
i mean i think sometimes that happens
though where i see artists like
they come out swinging with such a big
song and they almost get like lost in
the sauce of that record
nah for me it's like i'm happy we got
might not and i'm happy you did what it
did and and the sound just
was was so fun video was crazy you know
the video was crazy all that but that's
that's that's its moment you know i'll
never try to recreate that moment again
you'll never get that moment again talk
about your relationship with nipsey man
i'm nipsy somebody who you know i was
close with since about 09
um one of the greats uh you're
on arguably one of the best songs on
victory lap
um you know he i i know i'd always see
all the exo guys around nip like any
time he would do an activation i'd see
nav over there
talk about y'all's relationship man uh
when i first came to l.a man nip was
somebody that was just like just like
like instantly you know a friend it was
crazy like
um just like two three weeks and then
knowing that i felt like i knew him for
like 10 years
right he was that kind of guy for sure
yeah and he would and like he would pull
up to the house
uh you know he would come through with
slow mm-hmm shout out to slow slow was
living with me at the time and um
um studio city
and nipple pull up man and just like it
wasn't even about like working it was he
wouldn't even want to
you know not like he wouldn't want to
but he wouldn't even play his records
he'd just be like
let me hear what you're working on i
thought that was so dope because you
know every rapper is getting everybody
wants to play you their [ __ ] and they're
like yo where's the ox you know that's
the ox he was always just like now let
me i want to hear what you're working on
like he was just
genuinely like you know always always
interested and
and and whatever was going on it was it
was vice versa you know like
i was always a fan of nip uh it wasn't
just from
when we met before we met i was a fan of
them right right i mean so
i made sure i let that be known you know
throughout the whole course of us
working together and and being friends
and all that
i let people know the the level this guy
was on was different you know what i'm
saying like it was
it was something special to see somebody
like that come around
and double up like was that something
that was pretty much
like done and then you you you added
your partner like how did that
how did how did you end up on that song
because it's an like i said one of the
best songs on
on the project for sure um man they
brought me the song and we're like
uh basically you know nip been wanting
to work with you on something whatever
like he doesn't know that we're giving
you this so just you know do your thing
and then we're just gonna
basically like you know play a form and
be like yo you know what i mean yeah
and um yeah it was nuts bro like i
remember
i did this there's way more of that song
that never made it to the song
you know did you have a verse on it ever
i had a verse on the song
it was funny because that was when i
first got that [ __ ] victory lap
on spotify that was the first song i
went to and i was so disappointed that
you didn't rap on
i mean you did your thing on it but i
was like i was like oh
belly and nip that part that uh
nip ended up using throughout the song
that was that was like uh my outro
after my verse so that was like you know
that's how like i kind of ended my verse
and um but it was it was it was long as
[ __ ] man
it's a long song currently that's what
i'm saying the song is going to be like
7 minutes and 45 seconds right
i never i was never like damn why didn't
you keep you know i was just
happy to be part of it that project was
a classic
to me the first time i heard it i was
like this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
a masterpiece you know in our world
that's a masterpiece right there
a hundred percent man yeah i i think we
get one of those albums like every few
years
where we're like yo this will live
forever you know what i'm saying
and i think i think your album might be
one of those man you know what i'm
saying
man i hope so bro like
you know i make this [ __ ] between four
walls i think i told you this when you
came
you know because you were one of the
first people that that came through and
listened to the full length
yeah mastered versions of the songs you
know i think i told you that like you
had your producers locked in
your guys over there it's hard cause you
make [ __ ] between four walls
and it's like you're the only opinion
that's on it you know what i mean so
sometimes things feel personal to you
for certain reasons
uh but if you know you're being biased
because again it's your song it's like
nah but i said this and that [ __ ]
resonate doesn't matter none of that
matters
now when you leave the four walls and
you know people like yourself come
through and
and listen that [ __ ] is really
nerve-wracking to me because i'm like
nobody's heard this [ __ ] yet like i
don't know i tell now i still get like
butterflies about it and
i don't know like you know i still get
like kind of nervous about it before
i play the music for the first time for
people you know what i mean
and we have no idea when it's coming out
yet probably before the end of the
summer uh assuming yeah yeah i mean
yeah i think probably towards july
when's the beginning of the summer we're
in the summer right now i was just in
arizona it was 118 degrees so
we're going to palm springs this weekend
it's going to be [ __ ] it's going to
be up there 20 degrees tomorrow
jesus 120
120 yeah you're going out there just to
create right
maybe hero dose yeah i mean just maybe
just let go man
it's a lot that's a lot man yeah man
there it is
um anything i mean i i know we talked
you're gonna be doing some weed [ __ ]
soon um the book
hopeful so this book that you're gonna
write this is like for
like you're going through with this for
sure this is like something where yeah
yeah yeah i'm um
like the but it's not one book two i got
a few ideas this is
just the one that i'm like most
confident with because this is like
something that i just
this is the era that i'm just coming
through now so everything's still fresh
in my mind i could talk about it
and talk about all the benefits that i
had from it so you know it's crazy
because you're such a movie buff
uh would you ever consider like like and
you're such a great writer would you
ever consider like writing [ __ ]
screenplays
yeah i would love to man i just feel
like
um that's like not my area of expertise
so you know
i would want somebody to just kind of
show me the ropes you know
and i always feel like that like uh it's
just good for somebody
that's in that world that knows the
little ins and outs just the little
things that people look for like you
said you're gonna do this book with like
an author right where you just kind of
same kind of [ __ ] right yeah cause i'm
you know like
i could write man but i'm not gonna sit
there and write a book it's just not
going to happen no yeah no
i'm questioning race is too fast yeah
you know so
it's a good way to do it i just get the
the writer there and then i go on my
little rants
and before you know it man we got books
you know what i mean because
this is real [ __ ] that i went through so
when i talk about it i can talk about it
clearly every time this is all [ __ ]
that's still
fresh in my mind that affected me you
know in big ways so
um have you decided uh
you know i think when i engaged my wife
we got married
like inside of two years i was like yo i
don't want to be one of these [ __ ]
guys
who's engaged for [ __ ] five years and
everyone's asking where the [ __ ]
wedding is
i was like we've tried to figure this
out as fast as possible have you have
you thought about like where you guys
want to get married yet
we want to get married at the house man
you know at our house
i think you had told me that yeah that's
where we want to get married like we
all this you know big extravagant crazy
[ __ ] like
i just want make sure all our loved ones
are there
and it also kind of weeds out like
having to invite too many people because
you could be like
yeah you know we're doing it at the
house it's small it's private no
sweating
it's cozy yeah cause if you if you if
you get like the big venue
and you don't invite like every rapper
friend you have
you know what i'm saying oh yeah
especially like just all the random
industry people you know it's like no no
we did it at the house it was private
you'll have a diss record coming up the
next day oh man
anyway we'll listen bro uh the album is
hopefully coming soon see you next
wednesday it is coming soon
the new record with the money back yo is
out
go play that [ __ ]
weekend and nas is on the album
sir video's already shot yep video shot
man
was it was it whose idea was to put
knives on it
honestly i can't remember exactly whose
idea it was but
um you know shout out to anthony and nas
you know it's just it's like uh it's an
extended family thing
yeah and then obviously the the next
buck of this feature you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna get i'm putting in
the air it's
to be the whole record whenever you get
the whole record it'll be big
i can't wait for that it's gotta it's
gotta happen yeah like
i don't know i don't think i'll ever
retire if i don't get that one right
there
it's funny yeah benny said the same [ __ ]
he's like he's like yeah he's like and
he signed
you know i mean obviously you're right
nation as well but it's like he's he's
almost like
betty's such a big j fan he's like i
don't feel like i ever feel accomplished
until i get that song
yeah i feel the same way like you know
this man like
when i write my raps i always pretend
like he's hoes getting ready to grade me
you know what i mean
what's your favorite j album oh that's
tough man
that's tough um obviously reasonable
doubt
for me it's reasonable down that's just
because that was my introduction yeah
i mean i think his most slept on album
though
and i think people don't give this album
enough love because there's some
[ __ ] on it it's blueprint too
i love blueprint2 that song meet the
parents is like one of the best
storytelling songs
of all time like whenever i like tell
people like i'm like yo go to [ __ ]
blueprint 2
press play i'll meet the parents and
like listen to it five times in a row
it's like a quentin tarantino movie on
on wax yeah no he's different man
hovers been different he's been
different bro yeah who's that dude man
yeah he's literally the blueprint that's
why i made so much sense to call his
album that cause he's he's literally the
blueprint for
the the the epitome of what a rap life
should look like
what somebody that came up in the
streets and turned to rap
turned into a mobile agency he's showing
you the way the business the
everything man every aspect of his life
you know i mean he's really the epitome
of what
all of us should be aspiring to be you
know well look
see you next wednesday coming soon belly
go [ __ ] with them and we're going to get
some weed from you soon too